>>> IDAHO'S QUADRUPLE MURDER
SUSPECT WILL BE HEADED BACK TO
THE STATE TO FACE HIS CHARGES.
BRYAN KOHBERGER IS HIS NAME.
HE DIDN'T FIGHT EXTRADITION IN A
PENNSYLVANIA COURTROOM EARLIER.
HE'S A CRIMINOLOGY GRAD STUDENT.
HE'S ACCUSED OF STABBING FOUR
UNIVERSITY OF IDAHO STUDENTS TO
DEATH.
HE APPEARED TO HAVE MOUTHED "I
LOVE YOU" AT ONE POINT TO HIS
FAMILY.
WEEKS BEFORE HE WAS ARRESTED HE
WAS STOPPED TWICE BY POLICE ON A
LONG DRIVE CROSS-COUNTRY WITH
HIS FATHER.
THEY DIDN'T KNOW AT THE TIME HE
WAS A SUSPECT.
THEY DIDN'T KNOW YET TO BE ON
THE LOOKOUT FOR A WHITE HYUNDAI
ELANTRA.
WE NOW HAVE BODY CAM FOOTAGE OF
ONE OF THOSE TRAFFIC STOPS ON
DECEMBER 15th IN INDIANA.
>> LICENSE AND REGISTRATION.
WHEN YOU WERE DRIVING BY ME --
>> THAT WAS MORE THAN A MONTH
AFTER THE MURDERS.
IT WAS HARD TO HEAR.
THE OFFICER TOLD THE SUSPECT HE
WAS PULLED OVER FOR DRIVING TOO
CLOSE TO A TRUCK IT.
CNN'S JEAN CASAREZ IS OUTSIDE
THE COURTHOUSE WHERE KOHBERGER
APPEARED.
WHAT IS THE LATEST TONIGHT
FOLLOWING HIS APPEARANCE IN
COURT?
>> Reporter: WELL, HE SIGNED THE
PAPERS, THE EXTRADITION PAPERS
IN COURT.
SO THEN THE JUDGE DECLARED THAT
HE WOULD BE EXTRADITED TO IDAHO.
BUT THAT IS THE LAST WE'VE
HEARD.
NO ONE WILL CONFIRM IF HE IS
STILL IN PENNSYLVANIA, IF HE IS
IN FLIGHT AT ALL.
IF HE IS REMAINING HERE FOR THE
NEXT FEW DAYS.
NO ONE IS CONFIRMING THAT.
SO WE'LL JUST HAVE TO WAIT
BECAUSE THERE ARE SAFETY
CONCERNS AND THEY HAVE PUBLICLY
TOLD US ON THE RECORD THAT THEY
JUST DON'T WANT THAT RELEASED AT
THIS POINT BECAUSE OF ALL OF
THOSE POTENTIAL ISSUES.
>> YOU WERE SITTING RIGHT BEHIND
HIS FAMILY IN THE COURTROOM I
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT WAS THEIR REACTION?
>> Reporter: VERY EMOTIONAL.
STUNNED.
THEY WALKED IN.
HIS MOTHER WAS JUST DISTRAUGHT.
SHE WAS SITTING THERE.
AND WHEN HE WALKED IN, HE LOOKED
AT HIS FAMILY BUT HE LOOKED
DIRECTLY AT HIS FATHER.
AND HE ACKNOWLEDGED HIM.
SERIOUSLY.
BUT HIS HEAD WAS ACKNOWLEDGING
HIM.
HE SAT WITH HIS PUBLIC DEFENDER,
THE CHIEF PUBLIC DEFENDER,
TURNED AROUND A SECOND TIME,
BEELINED FOR HIS FATHER, LOOKED
AT HIM.
AND THEN THE THIRD TIME HE
LOOKED AND TURNED AROUND HE HE
SCANNED HIS FAMILY AND JUST SORT
OF HAD A VERY FAINT SMILE.
BUT WHEN THE PROCEEDINGS STARTED
THE PRESIDENT JUDGE REALLY
STARTED TO QUESTION HIM, IS THIS
VOLUNTARY?
HAVE YOU BEEN FORCED?
HAVE YOU BEEN COERCED?
SHE REALLY WANTED TO MAKE SURE
IT WAS FREELY AND VOLUNTARILY
BECAUSE HE HAS RIGHTS IN
PENNSYLVANIA AND HE CAN ASSERT
THOSE.
BUT HE SAID IT WAS.
AND SHE SAID, THEN YOU WILL BE
RETURNED TO IDAHO TO FACE
HOMICIDE CHARGES FOR MURDER.
HIS MOTHER THEN JUST SORT OF
FELL INTO THE SHOULDER OF HER
DAUGHTER.
YOU COULDN'T HEAR HER, BUT SHE
WAS CRYING SO HARD.
THE COURT BRINGS OVER A KLEENEX
BECAUSE AT THIS POINT THE WHOLE
FAMILY IS VERY EMOTIONAL AND THE
WHOLE FAMILY, THEY'RE TAKING THE
KLEENEX.
BUT AFTER THAT THEN HE SIGNED
THE EXTRADITION PAPERS AND THEN
IT WAS ALMOST OFFICIAL, BUT ONE
THING THAT THE DEFENSE ATTORNEY
WANTED TO PUT ON THE RECORD,
WHICH WAS VERY INTERESTING, THAT
THE CHIEF PUBLIC DEFENDER OF THE
COUNTY IN IDAHO HAD FILED UNDER
SEAL A MOTION IN IDAHO THAT HIS
FOURTH, FIFTH, AND SIXTH
AMENDMENT SHOULD BE PRESERVED.
HE SHOULD NOT BE INTERROGATED,
HE SHOULD NOT BE SEARCHED, THERE
SHOULD NOT BE SEIZURE, TO
PROTECT HIM.
AND HE WAS MAKING THE COURT
AWARE OF THIS, ESPEC